Alhamdulillah. Continuing
[Silence]
in
and we are discussing the chapter
regarding the beginning of Ramadan, the
end of Ramadan, moon sightings and so
forth.
Continuing where we left off yesterday
morning and we had left off basically if
we boil it down that in order for the
month to
be considered a a valid sighting of
the moon for the month of Ramadan is at
least one trustworthy
person Muslim
And
a siding of two people is required for
the beginning of Sha, the 10th month.
And we discussed this at length. We
discussed the evidences for this.
forth.
[Silence]
He says
there's a narration collected by
And it's a statement of alithb
one of the governors of Mecca
he said the messenger of Allah
sallallahu alaii wasallam taught us and
left us with the knowledge with the
commandment that we are to begin our
warship and begin our and specifically
our worship for hajj. So, the month of
Dulah
upon seeing the crescent, the
crescent of
and if we did not all see it, but two
trustworthy
individuals
inform us that they did see it, then we
will begin and commence our month of
worship. based on their testimony.
So we have here Iban Omar tells the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam. I
saw the crescent for Ramadan. He fasted
and told everyone else to fast based on
the testimony of Ibar.
And we have elsewhere that outside of
the month of Ramadan, all other 11
months and specifically
is a minimum of two trustworthy
testimonies that they have seen the
crescent for the foraram
for
etc.
And the same goes for the end of the
month.
[Silence]
for
10B.
forch.
[Silence]
He says a point here that needs to be
understood
is that
we now have understood the bare
minimum of what is required for
testimony in words in in terms of
testimony for citing the crescent of
Ramadan. Now, this is, as we mentioned
before, this is something that is for
the leadership to determine. However,
the general masses of the Muslim, when
do they fast? The author here tells us
that if a person were to hypothetically
see the crescent of Ramadan on his own
and people did not fast and the rest of
his community did not fast
meaning they didn't have a sighting or
whatever then the person would not fast
on his own because the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam has said
according to Abu
fasting begins when you all fast and
breaking your fast
happens when you all break your fast and
slaughtering on
the 10th of
is when the majority slaughters. So as
we've mentioned before that the
individual person
there is no such thing as a minority
of people fasting while a majority of
their community are not. The month is
not the crescent itself. The month is
indicated by the crescent. The month
commences officially when the majority
of our community begin to fast. The end
of Ramadan is when the majority of our
community break their fast. etc.
He says
[Silence]
He says, "And so one of the common
mistakes that people make is that and
this is speaking more towards
even for us it applies honestly that
u
if we were to go back to the days before
the internet, if we were to go back to
the 60s,7s, 80s, right? And even before
that, some of our elders here that are
with us now can recall this. And that is
that how did Ramadan usually start?
Well, it started we would contact home
wherever that is. Whether you're from
Fallstine or you're from Jordan or
you're from Pakistan or you're from
India, people would be in contact on the
phone with their family members. And
when they would have the official
announcement in their country that they
are commencing fast, they would fast
with them. And this is how it went for a
long time. And that is correct. Nothing
wrong with that. especially being that a
moon sighting happening all the way in
the east by deduction will
happen in the west even if we don't
necessarily
see it because of clouds or what have
you. But as things became more
as things became more generalized,
this has become less and less of an
issue because before you'll have people
that are from
people that are following Saudi, for
instance, are fasting on a day different
than those who are following Libya or
those who are following Morocco or
people from Jordan are fasting on a day
different than the people that follow
al. And so the issue became that in
America here we'd have sometimes even in
the same household in the same house.
Could you imagine some of the family
members are fasting and others are not.
Some are having Eid. They're putting on
their Eid clothes and going out to Eid
while the others are sitting at home in
their rags waiting for Eid tomorrow and
they're fasting, right? And I'm sure
that many of us here can remember that
this
largely was driven by politics largely.
Not always, but largely because after
all, how could the Khalij countries
Saudi, Kuwait, etc. fast on the same
time as Iraq after what they did in
Kuwait after the Gulf War? Absolutely
not. We have what you know what happens
to our dignity if we do that. And so
we've got people fasting with one
country, others fasting with another
country, and then it becomes a point of
contention. Who are you loyal to? What
is your view on the Gulf War? What is
your view on the Iranian Iraq war, etc.
And so these things have thankfully,
alhamdulillah, phased out a lot.
However, it's still has its remnants in
our communities.
We are not living in Iraq. We're not
living in Saudi. We're not living in
Jordan. We're not living in India. We
are living in America. And so we all
need to fast with each other and break
our fast with each other. not just in
the same masid but in the same general
area in the same town in the same
village in the same city and there is no
excuse for us to be differing on these
kinds of things. Alhamdulillah for the
most part we have this togetherness and
these are issues that are debated
amongst as we mentioned the leadership
of the communities. What kind of
sighting are we going to go with? Is it
an international sighting? Is it a
regional sighting? Is it a local
sighting? Etc. When I lived in the
Caribbean for many years, there are
the population is 1.5 million
for the whole country.
And the Muslim population is about 10%
10 to 12% which is a huge minority,
right? Muslims everywhere.
And you arrive there and you think,
"Wow, this is amazing. Islam has really
taken off down here." And you see how
many masids there are. If you could
imagine how many masids there are for a
100,000 people. Not all of them are
practicing. Not all of them are going to
the masid. More than 250
mids in this little little little
country. Why? You think, "Oh, mashallah,
the Muslims needed it." No, that's
actually not the case. The case is is
that everyone who goes to a masid, you
got a group that go to a masid, they
disagree with the masid. They say, "I'm
going to build my own masid." And then
they go and they put their little plot
and they build their own masid. And then
then those people that branched off and
built their own masid, then they differ
with each other. And the other one goes
across the street and builds another
masid. So you've got dozens of massagid
literally some of them across the street
from each other,
okay, with only 10, 15 people in it. And
when the moon sighting for Ramadan would
come around, oh my goodness, you have
people fasting, you'd think that it's
only two choices, right? But actually
some of them would be fasting in a
difference of three and four days from
each other. This differing is one of the
most major sins
a Muslim and a Muslim community can
commit. This division this you know
each person taking their own
initiative to do their own thing and all
this causes is division and discord. We
have to be patient with each other,
right? that is the nature of
leadership. The nature of leadership is
that the follower doesn't necessarily
always agree 100% with leadership, but
we have to be able to
say to ourselves,
we have to have good thoughts about each
other, not be suspicious. And we cannot
just say if things don't change in
this way I'm going to go do my own
thing. Sometimes that may be necessary
if there are drastic it's in a drastic
situation but for the most part the
default is we are patiently to each
other. We don't just retreat and do our
own thing. We stick together and we work
out our differences. It's kind of like
gears how gears work together. When you
put them together, each of the gears
begins to break in with each other.
So, little chips of steel come off on
this gear and little chips come off on
this gear until they find their harmony.
Right? There has to be a level of
cooperation and there has to be a
general adherence to follower and leader
otherwise we'll never get anything done.
If if everyone is a leader who's going
to follow
right and so tomorrow inshallah we
will start on some of the rulings of
fasting.
Fore! Fore! Fore!
Wasam.